hello everyone it's a rest day in the
2018 ulti box Norway championships so
it's a very nice opportunity for us to
check out some of the games we might
have missed during the coverage of this
very nice tournament and now regarding
the photo challenge from the previous
video of course it's Anatoly Karpov in
Salvador Dali I am beyond impressed by
our vast knowledge so this time we're
gonna we're gonna make it a bit more
interesting some of you might find it
easy but you know there are there are
beginners watching these videos so it's
very important we cover you know mostly
all of the players so here we have it I
hope you all know who it is
here he comes and as a bonus question
what is the name of a certain famous
game he played so there we have it
now let's let's get back to this video
what's the idea here here we have a game
between a visit
Gujarati he's a very strong Indian
Grandmaster well established in the 2700
club and of course with the black black
pieces we have the legend himself Boris
Gelfand and we do have a couple of
photos from this from this match up here
we have it there's a fan on the left and
with it on the right and here another
nice photo from the front middle of the
game yes I'm definitely having having a
tough time here but the game is played
in round five of a very strong
tournament it's the Karpov international
tournament played in a very small
Siberian town of pukowski
and it features 10 of very strong
grandmasters I will show you the
standings already 8 rounds have been
placed by which over the standings and
we can check out all of the players who
are playing in this tournament but it's
a very exciting game you know really
really an exact exciting one and there
are a couple of nice puzzles food to
solve so let's check it out
vid it has the white pieces and he opens
with sorry about this let me just let me
just input that my PC shut it down so I
so I missed
okay ready he opens with E 4 we have c5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and we have
Bishop to b5 so once again the
measurement Dean of or the Rosalie
management team of attack against the
Sicilian g6 Bishop captures B captures
and now castles Bishop to g7 rook to e1
we have knife to h6 c3 preparing d4 get
from the castles d4c capture some d4c
capture some before and now d5 we have E
5 + f6 and this is a very popular line
that has been played many time and many
times between well masters international
masters even even the top grandmasters I
think in in April in the Croatian
championship even cherish will have this
position against Hunter College and he
won't a very nice game with east sex
here but in this game with it goes for
Queen to c2 a nice development
developing also eyeing the c6 bone
immediately Bishop to g4 threatening to
capture an f3 and ruin White's pawn
structure in front of the king so Knight
B to d2 defending the knight we have
Queen to b6 a nice developing move for
Queen also guarding the c6 pawn and h3
now a forcing black to decide what to do
with the Bishop e3 is he he's gonna
capture an f3 or move back so first we
have F captures on e5 a very nice very
nice piece sacrificed by bodies get
found
so what do you do here definitely the
best move is to capture the bishop
otherwise you're just in a worse
position so we have HK % g4 with it
except the piece sacrifice Knight
captures and now comes Knight to c4
it immediately giving back the piece but
it would be very dangerous to try and
and and keep this extra piece you can
never do anything with this pawn white
black Center is really massive because
the night and and queen are really
pressuring that f2 pawn and there's
really and there's no H point so there's
really no way to get rid of the night
and black is extremely active white
doesn't really have a good move here so
nice to see four and this is in fact the
strongest move recommended by the engine
so giving back the piece but you know
not allowing not allowing Boris to gain
so much activity
Boris accepts the piece back he captures
on c4 Queen captures on c4 this comes
with check on the King to h8 and the
Queen to e6 now a very nice active
square for the Queen also this comes
with an attack on the g4 night so rook
to f5 there was a very interesting line
Knight captures on f2 after night
capture skin captures now pawn captures
with some terrible threats of d3 a
discover check
but after King to g1 why a white will
defend very nicely here and although you
can't you probably can't play this black
will have compensation for the
sacrificed piece but you know you would
have to be extremely motivated and you
know you'd have to feel really creative
to go to go into this but it's you know
round five I guess but Boris didn't want
to risk too much so after Queen to e6
rook to f5 and rope to f5 is indeed the
strongest move recommended by the engine
this blocks the Queen's attack towards
the knight and also a nice development
move for the rock maybe ideas like rook
to h5 will be possible in the future so
the rook will be able to join the attack
we have rook to e4 now once again
attacking the knight Knight to f6 and
rook captures on e5 now and here Boris
sacrifices the exchange rook captures on
f3 a very nice idea G captures on f3 and
now Queen captures on d4 so Boris did
sacrifice the exchange here but white
still has to develop both the bishop and
the rook and the white king is a very
very naked there on g1 so Bishop to e3
of course you have to develop your
pieces Queen to be to capturing another
pawn and look to see one and what do you
do here here Boris played Queen rook to
f8 and roof to f8 is a very important
defensive move if you try some tricky
ideas like maybe Knight to g4 opening
a double attack towards the rook and
also you know threatening a lot of ideas
capturing the bishop for example then
you remove the defender of the rook the
problem is you immediately get Queen
captures on c6 and now Queen captures
rook will come with check so once you
prevent this a queen has to go back now
you simply capture and black doesn't
really have any more threats but you
also have to see that Queen Queen to h2
check is it's alright for white after
King moves now comes Knight captures
rook captures and after black defense
now rook to e8 and the black really does
not have compensation for the exchange
so after something like Queen at forque
would have captures captures and white
can even exchange Queens so there's
really no compensation here for the
exchange sacrificed so after work to see
one rook to f8 we have rook captures and
c6 by visit Knight to g4 now now the
idea is possible because there is no
rock on e8 that the Queen can use to
Riemann over herself rook to e4
now comes Knight captures on e3 rook
captures on d3 and Bishop to f6 now rook
to see it of course we did wants to
exchange that as he is up up the
exchange so Rho captures Queen captures
and now King to g7 getting out of check
Queen to e6 and now comes Queen to c1
check King to g2 and if you look at this
position yes white is better white is up
the exchange but the e7 pawn and the
bishop on f6 are very nice counter play
against the Queen and rook I mean at a
queen and rook is better than a Queen
and Bishop but how do you break this how
do you break the e7 and the d f6 Bishop
this is a very nice barrier like
elephant so Queen to c5
you know he's a playing actively he's
sacrificing material but still you know
it's a very safe position to be it rook
to e4 now comes a 5f4 we have Queen to
c2 now comes f5 and g5 now now creating
a very nice wall here and it will be
very very hard to break through this we
have a for the rook for me for is
guarding the a four-pound very nice
quinta d1 with maybe with ideas that if
white tries to tries to break open with
their fourth and queen to g4 will be an
idea
so rook the c4
we have h5 Queen to e4 and now g4 it
seems like not only it does get found
not wanna keep you know the the pawns
stable but he's also marching them
forward so he likes his position and he
wants to attack so we have g4 rock to c7
and now Queen to d7 rope to a7 attacking
the a5 pawn queen to c5 defending and
rock back to d7 Queen to a3 with ideas
of marching the Queen over 2 H 3 and
here we have worked to d3 blocking this
Queen to c5 we have worked to d8 and now
again Queen to c3 with some ideas of
Queen coming to h3 and Queen to e6 here
with it actually allows it so what would
you do here in this position so would
you go Queen f3 check or maybe Queen h3
check or maybe or maybe none of this
well the important thing for you to not
to do is queen to h2 Richard if you play
Queen to h3 check then you have just
lost the game after King do you want
there's really no good move here for
black after g3 you are threatening some
checkmates but here comes Queen to g8
check King has to move and now Queen to
g6 will be checkmate so this would be a
very hasty idea Queen to f3 is possible
but Jeff and likes to keep all of his
options open so he goes King to h6 first
King to h6 and now what do you do here
well here rook to g8 was played we have
Queen to f3 check King to g1 and now
Queen to d1 check King to h2 and now
comes h4 if you try something like Queen
to d6 check it doesn't work you can't
you know do something like this and
maybe maybe try to push our best pawn
because then simply exchange and you
lose a piece here after the King moves
so Elektra King H 2 H 4 elephant
marches forward rock to g6 check King
moves and now rogue back to g7 Queen to
f7 being the threat a king back to h6 we
have Rock to g6 check came to h5 and now
rook to g7 once again and King to h6 and
here if with it would repeat rook to g6
check we would have a draw but the video
does not want a draw so he plays rook
captures on e7 of course the bishop is
spin so you cannot capture there but
King to g5 we have rook to e8 and now
comes Queen to c2 Queen to e3 check King
moves to h5 we have Queen to f4 and now
Queen to b3 with some with some very
nice ideas rook to e3 and not allowing
the Queen any Queen h3 check ideas we
have Queen thirty-one and now rook to e6
and here a brilliant move by by Boris he
plays Queen to f1 and what's the idea
behind Queen to f1 why why is he
allowing rook captures on f6 well well I
mean you can even pause the video if you
liked it so for those of you who were
able to find it congratulations you are
you are an excellent stalemate er and
for those who just wanna enjoy the show
if rook captures on f6 then g3 is coming
pawn captures H captors and g3 Queen
captures and g3 and now of course the
movie had to find Queen to h1 and after
King captures which is the only move
you have just achieved stalemate the
black King has nowhere to go and you
know it's a half a point and you managed
to save your position so very nice idea
so after rook to e4 with it doesn't
cover it he still would very much like
to win this position Queen to d1 not
allowing Queen to capture on g4 we have
Queen to c7 going for h7 now comes King
to g5 Queen back to f4 check King moves
and rook to e6 once again and again from
the repeats Queen to f1 so definitely
the idea is the same you cannot you
cannot capture the bishop on f6 so Queen
to e3
Bishop to g5 now attacking the Queen we
have Queen to d4 and now comes g3
I had this comes with check F capture
son g3 H capture son g3 King captures on
g3 and now comes the only the only move
okay now with it still up the exchange
and he has a passed pawn so it's a much
better position for white but there is
one idea
gelfand thought of that saved saved him
the game so once again pause the video
here and try to find girlfriends move
that the only move that doesn't lose the
game for black so I will give it a
couple seconds as usual for those of you
who found that congratulations you know
you are once again an excellent
stalemate and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy show the idea is Bishop to
f4 now as you see there is no move the
white king can make the bishop is
guarding h2 the Queen is guarding the
lights where's the king is guarding h4
so the King has nowhere to go
these all of these squares are covered
so the only possible move is actually
Queen captures on f4 which is the only
move with it good could play so Queen
captures on f4 comes and now comes Queen
to g2 check and now once again the White
King has no options he has to capture
the Queen King captures and g2 was
played and of course here the black king
isn't still mate there is nowhere he can
move to and it's a you know half a point
each so a very nice save by board is
getting fun the you know he first he
tried sacrificing a piece then he tried
sacrificing the exchange and then when
when it really didn't work out with it
was we really just kept finding the best
moves and in the end it was a it was a
very nice fighting draw and move 64 and
as we we've said we do have the
standings here are the standings of the
Karpov Koski tournament after round 8 so
Demetria coving who is first with six
and a half then Boris Gelfand second
with five and a half then yun upon me
actually with it with Rossi never admit
fellow civil era slavko olive intone
horrible Vladislav artemiev aim of the
top ski and victor
in last place with half a point out of
eight yeah I believe get from the one
his game in round eight he he played
against the victor Baldwin so now he
will will see how he will fare in the
next round and the will Boris may
perhaps be able to take this tournament
but yeah I will get back to you with
that of course so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it it's you know not
not very often you will see a nice save
like this in in you know such high level
chess I would like to thank Myles
Hayward Danny McCullough Chris of
Manny's alençon cobbles and host Palacio
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check through my previous
videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon with I'm gonna check out some
of the suggestions you have suggested
and if I found manage to upload anything
by then then with the next round on the
Norway chess championship thank you all
and I will see you soon and good luck
with the photo contest